grüße sie ja Ostermann viel zu Chef der
Deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft ja wie
dramatisch würden sie die Lage im Moment
in dieser flüchtlingskrise 2022
einschätzen
ja tatsächlich sehr dramatisch wir
weisen ja schon seit langer langer Zeit
darauf hin dass wir nicht kurz vor
2015 stehen sondern bereits inmitten
einer migrationskrise analog 2015 sind
wir haben die Bilder an der Einspielung
gesehen Potenzial für
radikalisierungsprozesse und natürlich
eine massive migrationsbewegung sind die
Folge und es wird jetzt Zeit zu handeln
im übrigen auch dazu Handeln wo es
gerade der absolute Schwerpunkt ist und
zwar an der Ostgrenze und das bleibt bis
zum heutigen Tage aus wenn sie Fräser
hat sich gestern beraten hat versucht
einen Plan zu machen wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll was halten sie von den
Plänen der bundesinnenministerin unter
anderem hat sie ja gesagt sie will jetzt
eben die Grenzkontrollen zu Österreich
verlängern
also zunächst einmal liegt die
bundesinnenministerin gold richtig wenn
sie sagt die Grenzkontrollen zu
Österreich werden verlängert denn auch
da nehmen die migrationsbewegung gerade
wieder deutlich Fahrt auf und da liegen
die Grünen in Bayern
ziemlich daneben wenn sie sagen die
europäische und das europäische der
europäischen Prozess wird da irgendwie
untergraben die Reisefreiheit wird nicht
stattgegeben hier ist die Sicherheit
dann erster Stelle und natürlich sie
europäische Einigung da nicht gefährdet
andersrum sagen wir auch ganz deutlich
an der Grenze zu Tschechien muss jetzt
was passieren da haben wir ein
migrationspapier und Maßnahmenkatalog
der bundesinnenministerin mit Datum vom
25.09 vorgelegt und bis zum heutigen Tag
passiert genau da nichts aber genau da
ist dreh- und Angelpunkt des
migrationsschwerpunkt und ich sage es
ganz bewusst ohne Ukraine Bezug genau da
muss jetzt was passieren und das bleibt
bis heute aus
finden Sie dass man diesen Zeiten wo wir
so explodierende Energiepreise haben wo
wir alle Sorge haben müssen einigermaßen
bezahlbar über den Winter zu kommen dass
man in diesen Zeiten strenger sein muss
noch in der Flüchtlingspolitik
nein also was heißt strenger sein wir
müssen unserer humanitären Verantwortung
natürlich gerecht werden und ich glaube
das macht Deutschland auch ganz Muster
gültig aber wir haben ein Rechtsstaat
und auch das muss gewährleistet sein
fakt ist doch eins Friedrich Merz hat
gesagt wir haben ordentliche und massive
pulfaktoren das ist schlicht und
ergreifend die Wahrheit und wir müssen
differenzieren wir müssen differenzieren
zwischen Schutz suchenden die auch ein
Anrecht darauf haben und anderen
Migrationsbewegungen und wir müssen ein
geordnetes strukturelles Verfahren
hinbekommen und deswegen fordern wir ja
die Einführung stationärer
Grenzkontrollen damit wir unsere
humanitären Verantwortung auf der einen
Seite gerecht werden die
Rechtsstaatlichkeit aber waren und ganz
klar differenzieren das tut der Debatte
unheimlich gut genau das zu tun und es
dient im übrigen der Sicherheit des
Landes und auch denjenigen die hier
tatsächlich ein Schutz ja suchen stellen
und auch ein gültiges gültigen Anrecht
darauf haben und deswegen sagen wir ganz
deutlich wir brauchen
ein an Zuwachs an an Kompetenz und
rechtlichen Verbindlichkeiten und das
fehlt bisher und die
bundesinnenministerin ist auch bis heute
nicht unser Schreiben eingegangen sagt
Manuel Ostermann von der deutschen
Polizei Gewerkschaft danke dass Sie sich
die Zeit genommen haben ich danke Ihnen
[Musik]